(♫♫)
>> MANY OF YOU WHO READ MY BOOK
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED, I THINK MY
SIZE AND KNEE AND SEXISM WAS
PART OF THAT CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS ONE OF THE CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS, SOME OF IT WAS
OLD-FASHIONED SEXISM AND A
REFUSAL TO ACCEPT THE EQUALITY
OF WOMEN, AND THE EQUALITY OF
WOMEN’S LEADERSHIP.
>> Tucker: EVEN A MAJORITY OF
AMERICAN WOMEN VOTED FOR A TRUMP
ALL WOMEN LOST WHEN HILLARY DID.
JUST YESTERDAY, BLAMING SEXISM
FOR HER 2016 DEFEAT WHICH IS
STILL ON TOP OF HER MIND.
JUST DAYS AFTER SHE WAS
DENOUNCED TOLERATING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ON HER VERY OWN
CAMPAIGN TEAM.
WATCH.
>> THE USE OF MY EMAIL ACCOUNT
WAS TURNED INTO, YOU KNOW, THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL SINCE LORD KNOWS
WHEN.
>> I WAS ON THE WAY TO WINNING
UNTIL A COMBINATION OF JIM
COMEY’S LETTER ON OCTOBER 28TH,
AND RUSSIA LIQUOR
WIKILEAKS WERE SCARED
OFF.
IF YOU LOOK AT FACEBOOK, THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE NEWS ITEMS
POSTED WERE FAKE.
THERE’S ALL THESE STORIES ABOUT
GUYS OVER IN MACEDONIA WHO ARE
RUNNING THESE FAKE NEW SITES.
HE CERTAINLY INTERFERED IN OUR
ELECTION.
IT WAS CLEARLY INTERFERED TO
HURT ME AND TO HELP MY OPPONENT.
THERE WAS A VOTER SUPPRESSION.
PEOPLE TRYING TO PREVENT OTHER
AMERICANS FROM BEING ABLE TO
VOTE.
I ALSO THINK I WAS A VICTIM OF A
VERY BROAD ASSUMPTION I WAS
GOING TO WIN.
I INHERITED NOTHING FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LOOK, I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
EVERY DECISION I MAKE, BUT
THAT’S NOT WHY I LOST.
>> Tucker: IT’S POSSIBLE IT’S
EASIER TO FIND PUBLIC
APPEARANCES BY HILLARY CLINTON
THAT DON’T INVOLVE BLAMING
EVERYONE IN EVERY PLACE FROM
MANHATTAN TO MACEDONIA.
WE HAVEN’T FOUND ONE YET.
BRIT HUME IS A SENIOR FOX
CLINICAL ANALYST AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
NOTHING FEELS MORE EMPATHETIC TO
HILLARY CLINTON, BRIT, THEN
APPEARANCES LIKE THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO WILL MAKE
WITH NO ONE IN HER LIFE TO PULL
HER BACK AND TELL HER HOW SHE’S
COMING OFF TO OTHER PEOPLE.
>> TUCKER, SHE REMINDS ME OF
OTHER PROMINENT PEOPLE I’VE
KNOWN WHO HAVE MADE A TERRIBLE
MISTAKE, HAD A BIG FAILURE.
RUN INTO TROUBLE.
THEY HAVE A VERY HARD TIME, SOME
OF THEM, OWNING UP TO IT AND
ADMITTING THEY WERE INVOLVED IN
A COLOSSAL FAILURE AND THEY ARE
TO BLAME.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HER
FAILURE, HER FAILURE TO WIN THIS
PARTICULAR ELECTION, SHE WAS UP
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP, A MAN WHO
WHO’S FAVORABLE RATINGS WERE
DEEP UNDERWATER THROUGHOUT
VIRTUALLY THE ENTIRE CAMPAIGN.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE MATH
APPEARED TO FAVOR HER ONGOING
OVERWHELMINGLY.
IT DIDN’T SEEM POSSIBLE SHE
COULD LOSE.
AND YET SHE DID.
THAT IS A VERY, VERY HARD THING
TO FACE UP TO.
I THINK SHE IS DOING HER BEST TO
FIND A WAY TO LOOK AT THIS AND
THE WAY TO FRAME IT THAT MAKES
IT APPEAR THAT SHE WASN’T REALLY
ALL THE BLAME.
OTHERWISE, I DON’T KNOW WHAT SHE
WOULD DO IF SHE DIDN’T HAVE THIS
CRUSH SHE IS DEVELOPED, ALL
SORTS OF OTHER REASONS.
>> Tucker: YOU’VE LIVED IN A
TIME.
DON’T YOU THINK THAT WHEN YOU
ACCEPT BLAME US THINGS, IT’S
LIBERATING, IT WILL MAKE YOU
FEEL BETTER WHEN YOU DO THAT.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
NOW AGAIN, I WILL GET ASKED TO
MAKE A GRADUATION SPEECH, MY
MESSAGE IS THE SAME TO YOUNG
PEOPLE.
OWN YOUR MISTAKES.
ADMIT THEM, FIRST OF ALL TO
YOURSELF, THAN ANYBODY ELSE WHO
MIGHT BE INVOLVED.
IT IS LIBERATING.
THE PECULIAR FACT OF IT IS THE
COUNTRY
CONTRARY TO HOW AND MY FEEL TO
YOU, IT MAKES PEOPLE FEEL BETTER
TO YOU THAN LESS.
I THINK IN HER CASE, THE BURDEN
OF THIS IS SO GREAT.
THE BURDEN OF ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
IN THE END, IT WAS HARD TO WIN
THE ELECTION ENGINE FAILED TO DO
SO AGAINST A CANDIDATE WHO
LOOKED LIKE HE COULD POSSIBLY
WIN.
I WOULD ALSO SAY, BY THE WAY,
TUCKER, THOSE MOST RECENT
REMARKS, THE ONES SHE MADE
YESTERDAY.
I DON’T THINK IT’S THE CASE THAT
AMERICA IS NOT READY FOR FEMALE
LEADERSHIP AND FOR A WOMAN
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE JUST -- THE COUNTRY
TURNED OUT NOT TO BE READY FOR
THIS WOMAN TO BE PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, SHE TURNED OUT NOT TO
BE AS SHE REFUSES TO ADMIT A
VERY EFFECTIVE CANDIDATE AND SHE
COMES WITH TREMENDOUS BAGGAGE
WHICH SHE’S ALWAYS BEEN HESITANT
TO RECOGNIZE AS WELL, GOING BACK
TO HER DAYS IN ARKANSAS AND
RIGHT THROUGH HER HUSBAND’S
PRESIDENCY AND BEYOND.
>> Tucker: AMERICA’S PRETTY